okay so I'm playing this game I'm right
up to the point where I'm gonna take on
the ball I've been down this road before
and I haven't succeeded but this time
I'm feeling really confident I think I
could do it this time and just as fast
more than Pegasus oh come on really okay
okay
now it's flashback to yesterday hi I'm
Tom Melendez I'm a satellite operations
Wrangler controlling small fleet
satellites taking ground images of Earth
as part of my job sometimes I have to
make remote software updates to these
satellites or even our ground patrol
systems I also manage the software and
systems used to process our image data
along with the website that lets you see
these images today one of our satellites
needed a hotfix applied right away I'm
going to show you how I use ansible and
Google cloud platform to apply the
topics ansible is a simple to use and
powerful IT automation engine that
handles provisioning orchestration and
configuration of all of your IT needs
and here to help me explain this is
Dylan he's a product manager at Ansley
thanks for having me here Tom I'm really
really excited to see how you're going
to use ansible to work on in a satellite
so the first part of patching a
satellite is to make sure we have a good
build and that we test it out we're
going to use my local laptop and ansible
to spin up a Google compute engine VM
for this first make sure you have a TCP
project the GCE API is enabled and a
service account created with the
appropriate permissions be sure to
download the JSON credentials class and
then obviously you're going to need an
swill installed on your laptop so we're
going to have you go to ansible calm and
hit our get starting page to install
ansible by using the instructions there
since I was paged I'm going to get the
provisioning test and push process
started and then we'll take a look at
the configuration I have an answerable
playbook I can use for this and all I
need to do on my laptop is type ansible
playbook push camera France and while
that's working Dylan do you want to walk
us through the playbooks of it yeah sure
so an ansible playbook is a human
readable format to holistically describe
an environment
in those play books you have tasks that
are by default executed sequentially in
order from top to bottom and those tasks
call ansible modules and what modules
are the toolkit in the language they are
what extends ansible and the simplicity
of the engine itself so based on what
i'm reading here i see that you have a
way for us to easily develop and test
against a satellite first the GCE VM is
being provisioned and you're also
pulling in some variables from external
files which are allowing you to use
those values without changing the play
books themselves right then we use that
technique throughout our playbook so
they can be version controlled as well
as be used to build different
environments as you see in our GCE tasks
we wouldn't want to check in our
credentials into source control that
would make the play books inflexible and
possibly allow for misuse and what are
some of the other options that you're
specifying here for the GCE module Tom
well we can specify one or more
instances that want to be created as
well as their zone
we also are specifying an image which in
our case is a custom Debian image that
includes our County and I also see that
you have a post task to wait for SH to
come alive before moving on with the
PlayBook that's a really good convention
to go with let's have a look at the
PlayBook that runs a test shall we sure
I'm really anxious to see what else
you've written here all right so what we
have here is a task that is being used
to test some binaries it looks like
you're running a command using the
command module and pulling in some
variables associated to hosts from
various variable files you'll see for
hosts we've explicitly set that value to
the group name from the previous
playbook okay and then based on that the
nice thing is that camera test instances
can be as few or as many hosts as you
really need so this plate will only run
those tests against the hosts that you
specified no change is necessary that's
pretty cool now assuming the tests have
passed we can actually push the camera
configuration to the RDS which will then
send it to the satellite on the next
and to do that it looks like you took
advantage of a couple of community
modules to write out that data and you
also written your own custom module that
doesn't come with an s' bolt to push the
data to the satellite correct
our updater code requires in any file so
we use the any file module to create it
with our camera parameters then we
created a custom module that validates
the parameters and hands them to the
binary which submits them to the RDS
returning to us the status and the
encrypted string for debugging building
the custom module was easy and we just
place it in the library directory and
ansible picked it up cool all right
let's go back and step through the
output from our ansible playbook run
yeah let's do that
you can see that it did just what we
expected we use ansible to spin up a GC
EVM run some tests deploy a hotfix to
our satellite all from my laptop
cool and now you can get back to that
game and beat that boss I was thinking
the same thing thanks for watching us
today folks we'll be back soon to show
you a few more fun things you can do
with ansible
and Google cloud platform thanks for
joining me today going thanks for having
me Tom and don't forget to check out all
of our ansible modules at the URL below
[Music]